where the [ __ ] am i  ain't no way i'm gonna find an a on this  [ __ ]  what do you guys see geography can be  hard at the best of times so when you're  streaming for multiple hours a day it's  understandable that you might forget  where countries are on a map right  united kingdom move away from eu that  would be pretty small so i'm gonna go  over here  eu the capital of canada central 100  i have to announce to you that  this is not the zero what country are  you from  jordan  not your name what country are you from  wait the czech republic is here i  thought it was an island does the us own  czech republic where's  looks like the united states  i'm confused wait mount everest is in  nepal really i thought everest was in  the america was in america so this is  mexico  where's spain  it's mexico spain there's no sign  there's nothing i can't see anything  it's there's nothing there's no way to  do this it's not iceland there's no ice